サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
こちらに来る時突然思い出したんですけど
まあお釈迦様が人間に理解不可能な事柄がいくつか 4つありますということでね
で 認識範囲に入らないものがありまして
その中で心の法則というものも入ってるんです
そんなのはもう考えない方がいいやと
もう頭では理解できないんだと
余計に考えて理解しようと言っちゃうと
混乱してイカれてしまいますというね
業の話と宇宙の話っていうことの中に入ってされてまして
そういうことで じゃあ心が壊れないように気をつけましょう
今日はその心の話になります
よろしくお願いします
で というわけで 私たちに必要なところだけすごくシンプルにして説明していきます
あの宣伝文句にはいろいろ書いてあったんだけども
立ち触るしない あれやこれやと欲張っていろいろ用語を出しちゃっても
まあそこをちょっと心の働きっていうのは
まあちょっとややこしいんですね
理解する場合は しかし
仏教を学ぶ上では 心のことは理解しなくてはいけない
仏教っていうのは心の学問ですから
仕方がないことでもあります
まず 仏教は二元論であるという話に入ります
一切の現象はナーマ それからルーパです
すべて大宇宙のすべての存在
現象っていうのは 2つに分けちゃうんですね
ナーマとルーパ だから堂々と二元論を語っています
これでルーパっていうのは何なのかと
この漢字で色と書いてますけどね
これは物質ですね そこで科学世界はこの物質についてとことん研究していますね
具体的な世界ですね  最終的に素粒子というところには来ているでしょうね
素粒子はあるのかないのか
いろいろ問題あるんだけど
まあ我々から言えばエネルギーなんですね
エネルギーっていうのはものじゃないんですね
エネルギーからものがあるというふうに錯覚を起こるだけなんです
だから素粒子はものでなければ
どうやってものがあるのかと
それは組み立てるとそういう錯覚が起こるだけなんですね
はい だから物質 物理学は言う必要はないんだから
そこでした 次な これは科学者の科学世界では扱わないところで
ナーマっていうのは心ですね
だから宇宙の物質って膨大言って同じく心っていうエネルギーもありますよと
その中でどちらの方が強い
大きい 巨大かというと
心の方が巨大で強いっていうのは仏教の立場なんです
これからアメリカで誰かがそれを発見したら
皆さんは信じるだろうと思います
私言ったら なんだ これ嘘だろうと思っちゃうでしょうし
で で アメリカからそこを発見してくるまで言えば
我々は命が持つかどうかよくわかりませんだからね
さっさと理解した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
で 宇宙は 生命は心が支配して
心が作って 心が管理しているんだっていうお釈迦様の言葉があるんです
だから他宗教では神様がすべて創造して
作って 管理して面倒見ているんだと言うんですね
で こういう神様とやつではなく
仏教は心というエネルギーによって物事は現れて管理されて
まあ変化していくんだと
だから物事の変化終わり終わりにしたければ
それも心の仕事になるんです
それはどういうことかと
我々にはわかりませんね
どうやって心は宇宙を支配しているのかと
宇宙を支配していますが
それで心って何なのかというと
ものじゃないんです 認識機能です
ものを認識する だからファンクションなんですね
で 面白いことは ファンクションで我々は今も理解しています
扇風機ですと言ったら
なんであれは扇風機にしたんですか？機能なんですね
何かしらものを見て これはお箸ですと言うでしょ
なんで何か機能を持ってるんですね
その機能はやってくれないと名前がチャラになっちゃうんですね
過去形で言いますけど
割れたお箸ですとかね
ですから このいつでも私たちは何か認識して名前を付けたら
そこにそれが何か機能を持っている
何か仕事をしている その仕事をしているから
我々は物があると言っているんですね
だから一番大事なのはこの機能
ファンクションなんですね
これが私たちの頭でえーという理解しがたいんですね
ですから この 例えばこれを見たらマイクロフォンだとわかりますね
皆様の携帯でこれはどこがマイクロフォンですかね
でもマイクロフォンあることは知ってますね
よく見えませんだけど
どこにあるのかと で あることはなんで確認するのかというと
やっぱり我々の声を受け取っているんですね
だから声を受け取るという機能を持っているものは
マイクロフォンになっちゃうんですね
そのようにどんな言葉も調べてください
機能 仕事を持っています
だからこれはアビダンマの説明していますが
物質に我々はいろいろ名前を貼ってますよ
物質は自分なりの機能を持っています
機能によって名前変わります
例えばあったかい弁当を見たら
あ これはあったかいおいしい弁当やと名前を付けちゃう
これは古くなっちゃって腐っている場合は臭っている場合は
あ おいしい弁当だと言わない
なぜならば もう機能を失っちゃったんですね
別の名前に入れちゃうんですね
そういうことで 弁当はありますかないかっていうことは
ちょっと安っぽい話ですね
機能を持ってるのかないかなんです
レストランなんかではもうすごい品作ってますね
食べ物のね 全く同じ形でしょ
すごい上手に作ってますね
でもそれには我々はご飯とかなんとも言いませんね
なんとか別の名前を使うでしょ
なんていうか その場合
使う名前はもう商品ですかね
なんとか単語がありますね
その単語をなんで使うのかというと
その仕事をやってくれるんですね
食べこれから見せないで食べられるだろうと思う食べ物の形を見せるだけ
そういうことで いつでもものがあるという話が俗世間よく使ってますけど
あるんじゃないかとかね
機能がなければないんです
そういうわけで 心とは認識する機能です
だからあると言いたければ同そうなんです
本当は言う必要はないんです
じりじりと機能を持っています
なんで機能が大事かと
この機能 別な機能とぶつかると機能の変化が起こるんですね
だから世の中で起きているのは
この様々な機能が互いにぶつかっちゃって
絡み合って別な機能になる
だから酸素っていうものは別な機能を持っている
水素は別な機能を持つ
だから酸素水素あると言いたければどうぞと
これを酸素と水素が一緒にしておけば
我々のは水というものが出てくる
もう酸素もない 水素もない
その機能はもうなくなっちゃったんです
その代わりに別な機能になっちゃったんです
そういうわけで このファンクション機能ということを大事にしましょう
ファンクションがあるから
ものがあるのごとく感じてしまいます
しかし ファンクションが変われば変わるほど
まあそのあるのごとく
あったものも変わっていくんです
それで あの機能って物理変化するから機能でしょ
でなきゃ機能できませんだからね
宗教家は存在を体と魂と分析して
宗教家になってくると
宗教は科学世界ではないんです
仏教は科学世界ですが
宗教は信仰世界ですから
自由に語られます 成立成立する必要はない
証明する必要もない 言えばいい
だから世の中で一番簡単なのは宗教を作ることなんです
世間では難しいではね
人と喋るとかそんな簡単じゃないんで
今言ってることは本当かないかと証明しないと
でなきゃあんた頭おかしいって言われるんです
そこは宗教世界でないんです
そこで宗教世界は人間のことを体があって魂があると二つに
分析して 魂こそが実体で永遠不滅だと説きます
で 証明してくださいと言ったら
冒涜するなよと だけ 神様の話を
そこで宗教でね 人間に神様が魂を吹き込んだと言うんだけど
見たらね 我々と動物たちは何の差もないんでしょうに
なんであの連中に魂を吹き込んでないんですかね
魂を吹き込んでないのにちゃんと生きてるしね
時々我々よりも賢いしね
そんなこと言ったら まあ神様侮辱したことになっちゃって
間違えちゃって地獄に落ちるんですね
続いて すべては我であると一元論に進みます
特にインドの宗教哲学になってくると
一元論を語っているんですね
今 ヨーロッパでも一元論がすごい人気があるんですね
この一元論にまで進んだんだけど
これ この犯人が仏教なんです
仏教は最初に一元論を作っちゃったんです
あのナーガルジュナという人が空論と皆様聞いていますね
シューニャターパーサンスクリット語で
あれが一元論なんです
これ かなり立派に組み立てたんです
彼が明確に論理的に組み立てたんだから
信仰はいらない 立証はそのまま理論で立証されています
論理でね でもお釈迦様は論理だけでは立証しませんよと
実験も必要なんですね
論理はいくらでも組み立てられますからね
はい 次に行きましょう
命 生命の意味 妙識でいえば
全存在のことを二次元で見ることになります
例えば仏教でいうナーマルーパといえば
一切の存在 存在 神も入っています
ナーマとルーパというと
物質があって心がある
そうすると まあ宇宙の実態を語っているような感じなんですね
だから生命って何なのかという問題が出てくるんです
物質の一部を取り上げてみると
その物体に認識機能があるとしましょう
例えば 宇宙の無限に物質はあるでしょうね
物質の一部を取ってみる
空気でいいんです 空気をちょっと取ってみる
この空気に認識機能があるんです
ものを知ることは可能です
だったら その空気自体は生命です
難しい 我々は何ですかね
土から取った物質の一部でしょ
土から取った物質の一部なんです
認識機能を持ってるでしょ
だから生命なんです だから物質は必ず地球からいただかなくちゃいかんとか
そんな話はおかしい だからいろんな生命体はあり得る
だからいるかどうかはわからないんだけど
火星でも土星でも木星でも
そちらの物質で塊が現れちゃって
そこを認識機能を持っているならば生命です
それは個で生命です で
個がいる パーソン で 本当にパーソン
人間というものはいるか
まあいいかげん ただいろいろ物質が固まったところに認識機能があるだけです
だから変化しない不滅の個がいるわけじゃなくて
機能として個がいる それのファンクションなんです
例えば こちらのどなたかと私を比較しましょう
私も土からいただいた物質で
この個ができている 他の方も土からできた物質でその個ができている
でもファンクションが違う
私の認識機能とそちらの認識機能
それぞれ違いますから
違う二人がいるだけで
まあそれはファンクションで言うんですよ
例えば女性がいる 男性がいると言うでしょ
なんで？機能です 機能で言ってるんです
知る能力が集まっている物質によってリミットされます
知る能力が一緒でもリミテッド
いわゆる有限というか
何でも知ることはできないんです
要するに みんな好き勝手好き勝手っている全知全知全能
これはありえないんです
これはもう神話物語を信じる連中には
妄想の中でそんなことは信仰できますが
科学世界ではこれ全知はありえないんです
なぜならば 私が持っている物体持っているんだから
物体が知る世界をすごくカットするんです
これ難しくないんです
私がいる 私は猫を飼っている
猫の物質違うでしょ 私の物質は違います
二人とも土からもらったんだけどね
地球から しかし 猫が知る世界と私が知る世界違いますね
そこで猫に知り得ない世界もあります
私が知っているを猫が知っているが
私が知らない世界もありますね
そういうことで 知る世界はもう結構制限されています
だから人間も威張ってはならないんです
人間の肉体を持ったら
あんた知るのはこの範囲だよと
これ以上立ち入り禁止ということになるんです
例えばあなたにものを見えるんだけど
見える見えられる 見えるのはこの波長のこの範囲だけだと
それで終わり もっと見えるものあるのに見えないんです
聞こえる場合でもね 各生命体が知る世界は同一ではない
もう説明しましたね 各生命体
知る世界は同じじゃない
だから一卵性双生なんとかっていうね
双子であっても それぞれ知る世界は同じじゃないんです
奥さんが知る世界で 旦那さんが知る世界はそれぞれ違うんです
だから子はそんなもんなんですね
子はこの世界を作っているんです
生命の次元に行きましょうか
これ ちょこっと難しくなるかも
物体 体と心がある 生命
2次元の生命 体ある 心がある
物質がある 心がある生命
それはどんな生命か で
仏教の言葉で言えば 地獄餓鬼畜生人間神々というものなんですね
これは仏教用語で欲界と言うんですね
カーマローカ カーマって欲と書いているんだから
これ我々が考えている欲じゃないんです
物質っていう意味なんです
肉体って意味なんです
肉体ってちょっと言葉おかしい
まあ体 あとちょっとまた説明します
それから色界という次元があります
この次元にいる神々には梵天と言うんです
神々と言わないんです
理由は 神々っていうのは良い生活すれば良い人間になれば
死後天界に生まれます
梵天っていうのはそうじゃなくて
瞑想修行して心の次元を上げているんです
生まれつきついてきた心じゃないんです
これはもうかなり成長させているんです
だからそのエネルギーで梵天というふうなところに生まれますね
それで梵天にも体があるんです
それは色界というんですね
いわゆる物質あるっていう
2番目 物体がなく 心機能だけがある生命
物体がない しかし しかし
認識機能だけあるんです
ちょっとわからないでしょう
我々にはわからないんです
これは無色界の梵天なんですね
だから無色界というのは物質はありません
という梵天だから個性がある神々なんです
だから体がないんだから
どこにいるのかいということも
人間には把握できないんです
このこれはどういうふうにこの虫から生まれるかというと
この人間で修行して 体と心を離せる訓練するんです
これ並の努力じゃない
ものすごく瞑想しないといけないんです
順番に成長していって
どんどん体に対している依存していると
依存度を減らして減らしていって
離してみる そこをできる人々は
そこをさらに訓練して
リピートしてリピートして
経験しっかりしたら 死後無色界の梵天に生まれる
3番目の次元 心の機能がなく
物体だけの生命 これは一番変なんです
なぜならば 心の機能がなければ生命は消えないでしょう
でも これ成り立つんですよ
論理的だけじゃなくて
実際にもね これは決してこの瞑想をやってはいけないと
仏教では禁止しているんです
これは仏教用語でアサンギサッターというんです
次 分かりやすくそこら辺説明します
そうやってどれぐらい
3次元がありますね 物質が心を支配している世界は欲界といいます
もう欲界も知ってるんですね
地獄 餓鬼道 畜生 人間 神々
その場合は物質が偉いんですね
心よりも 我々もそうでしょう
我々は体言う通りに心変えちゃうんですね
物質に言われるように通りに生きてるんです
だから人間見たら物質に支配されています
我々は物質の奴隷なんです
携帯の奴隷でしょ いろんな物質を見て威張ってるんですね
偉いんだと 自分が立派な人や金持ちで立派な人というためにでっかい家を作って
もうごっつい豪華な車何台も買って買いまくっちゃって
物質で何言ってるんですかね
だからお釈迦様 仏教 我々は笑っちゃうんですよ
いっぱい糞を集めて威張るんだと
いわゆる土を集めてね
だから我々は土をたくさん集めて
どうだい 私はと あんたと違うでしょと威張ってるんですね
だから性格で能力でじゃないんです
例えばすごい知識 能力ある
もの桁違い しかしすごい貧乏
相手にしないんです 相手にしないんです
ノーベル賞を取ったならば
ものすごい もうバカでもすごい尊敬するんです
あれ 物質で だから決して必ずしもそのその年で一番優れた人への賞をあげるわけじゃないんです
いろんなカラクリあるんです
ノーベル賞をもらうべき人間はいくらでもいます
もらわない 物質ですよ
もう結局 そこで我々欲界の生命ですね
私たちの場合は 物質様いう通りに我々は生きているんです
それを説明します 眼耳鼻舌身意から色声香味触法という情報を取り入れて
心が回転するんです 生滅変化する次元です
だから物質にやられているということは
この眼耳鼻舌身意なんです
目がなかったら大変でしょ？耳がなかったら大変でしょ
味が感じなくなったら大変でしょ
そこで 目で見て 耳で聞いて
舌で味わって 身体で感じて
我々は生きているんです
いわゆる認識しているんです
目で認識する 耳で認識する
ということは 物質がなければ見えません
認識できなかったら生命ではありません
だから私たちの命は現に物質心が支えているんです
今入りますが 現に物質心が支えているんです
今はちょっと置いておいて
考えたっても まあ現に物質なければもう機能が失ったら終わり
死んじゃいます だからとことん物質に依存しなくちゃいけない神になっている
心が物質を支配している世界は色界です
あの梵天の世界 梵天にも体があるんですけど
現に物質心には依存していないんです
瞑想して自分で別なサマーディ認識できるんです
すごい力を持っていて
だから体はどうでもいいんです
サマーディの第一作るためにも
五感から離れなくちゃいかんです
五感に依存することを離れたところで
第一禅定が現れます ということは
色界の梵天の神々が物質を支配しているんです
目が合っても あんたちょっと待ちなさいと言える人々なんです
機能停止しなさいと 耳にやめなさいと言えるんです
音を取るのは我々に不可能でしょ
だから物質が支配しているのは欲世界
物質を支配しているのは色の世界です
体が心の居場所ですが
心は自由に禅定状態で活動します
この場合は この梵天の場合は
梵天の場合は体が必要です
体はただ居場所だけ で
心は自由に活動する  私たちにも家ってあるでしょうに
家はいる場所だけ 家に支配されている
支配されてない 家開けてはあかんだから
外を出られませんとかないでしょ
好き勝手に家に出入りしたり
家を使ったり 大丈夫です
でも 家がなければ困りますね
だから色界の梵天の状況は
家に住んでいる心は住んでいる主人ですね
体は家なんです 家が人を支配していない
冗談で言いますけどね
例えば京都いろいろある
この世界遺産に認定しているお寺とかありますね
あちらに住んでいる人々には存在価値がないんです
文化財を守るだけなんです
だから文化財にやられているんです
そこら辺に新しいお寺を作ったら
何のこともない 自分でも支配するんですね
物質に依存しないで 心は無色界で活動します
この無色界という梵天になったら
心は物質はいらない 自分一人で認識していくんです
だからそれは認識違います
我々はもう花があります
ホールがあります これはオリンピック青年センターですとか
いろんな認識でしょ そういう認識ないんです
だって物質関係ないんだから
まあそれ何認識来るのかありますけど
あんまり難しいんだから
カット今日は 要するにこの生命には体がないんですね
だから見るとか不可能です
聞くという 不可能です
感じるということは不可能です
だからお釈迦様は梵天にも神々に説法したんだけど
無色界の神々に説法できません
アドバイスすることはできないんです
だって持ってないんだから
次はサンサッタとは 修行によって心を一時的に停止させている生命体
あの修行方法もあまり仏典で書いてないんだけど
ほんの一行で終わってるんです
やるなようなんです 絶対
で 瞑想修行して心の機能ストップするんです
いわゆる認識することをストップするんです
ということは 肉体が突然物体になっちゃうんです
一回なったって意味がない
それは繰り返し繰り返し
もう手も物にしなくちゃいけないんですね
瞑想に入って もう体が物にしちゃった
すべてストップして物質にする
それは何回繰り返して
何回繰り返して その能力を持ったままで死んじゃったら
彼らが体 心がない世界に生まれるんです
ということは 仏教定義では生命とは言えないんです
だって認識機能を持っていないんだから微妙なんですね
このことなんです 再び心が活動するための居場所として
物質 体はあるんです あるが
電源を切った電気製品のような存在です
これでわかるでしょう
電源を切ったら 電気製品というのはただのモノでしょ？何の役にも立たないただのモノ
でも電気入れちゃえば働き出します
それでその修行者たちが死んじゃったら
体を持って生まれるんだけど
電気を切ってるんです
心を切ってるんです それで自分の業がね
終わってくると電源がオフになっちゃう
オフになった瞬間に死んじゃってどこかに生まれ変わるんです
だからもう広範囲でいますよ
物質だけだからね だから地球のことを我々
我々知っている世界で考えたらね
まず地球は物質だけでしたでしょ
地球に物質 ものすごい環境
おかしい 恐ろしい環境の地球がね
初めはもうもう火の玉でしたからね
そこに最初に生命体現れるまでどれぐらい時間かかったんですかね
だから結構時間かかります
そういうわけで この生命体は広範囲ですごい長い時間いて
パッと心が現れる 現れた途端消えなくちゃいけないんです
はい 次 どうやってこの次元決めるんですかね？誰が決めてくれる？例えばスマナサーラが今度死んじゃったら
まあ色界の餓鬼道どうですか？とかね
誰かパスくれる？あんたなら天国
はい どうぞと 極楽浄土
誰が決めるんですかね
当然 心ヴィンヤーナが決めなくてはいけない
心か認識機能が決めなくちゃいかんですよ
だからこれ単純ではありませんね
でも 例えば私はやっぱり死んじゃったら色界にでも生まれるかなとかね
決める 生まれる？生まれません
そう単純じゃないんです
じゃあ色界展開難しいんだけど
じゃあ私は死んじゃったら
じゃあ地獄にでも行きましょうかと
そうはいきませんよ 決めただけでは
それなりの心の法則を知って仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
心は認識することによってエネルギーを溜めます
これから法則 ちょっと説明します
心が認識しますね 認識機能だから
知る機能だから 知るたびにエネルギーが生まれるんですよ
例えば今チェックしてください
私の前にあるこの花を見る
それからスクリーンを見る
それからもう普通舞台を見るとかね
3つ見たでしょ？それそれ心のエネルギーが変わるんです
見る見るものによって
それでこちらもし猫ちゃんでもトコトコトコといっちゃったら見るでしょ？心のエネルギーが変わるんです
これ見るだけの話で そういうわけで
認識っていうのはものすごい光の速度より速く動きますよ
だから結構エネルギーが溜まっていくんです
業あるいは行 サンカーラと言います
このエネルギーに この蓄積するエネルギーに
それは物質エネルギーではありません
心のエネルギーなんです
例えば電気で言えばね
ワットというのは量でしょ
ボルトってありますね
あれは流れるエネルギーなんですね
ボルトの数字が高いほど遠く電気を飛ばせるんですね
我々使っている電池とかね
携帯のそれほどボルトが高くないんですね
だからあまり遠くは行かないんです
例えば高圧電線がありますね
あれはどこまででも引いちゃいますね
電気はもう押すエネルギーが強いんだから遠くへ行けるんです
電気で言えば このウォルト
ボルト ボルトですね ウォルツ
ボルテージ 英語の単語は電圧
それで我々は認識すると心のこの振幅が
溜まるんですね だから電気ほど電気は数字でわかりますからね
何ボルトですかと そんな単純じゃない
心の世界は だから心圧の数字で学びましょうと言ったっても
やめた方がいいんです
それだったらもういい加減
お釈迦様に説かれた心理学はナミダールもテキストを書いて出してますよ
宣伝していないが 読んでみた方が心の働きがそこら辺で我々に把握できる範囲で物事を語っているんです
地獄から梵天界までへの生まれは
各生命の心のポテンシャルによって起こるんです
だから私は認識する 認識するとポテンシャルが溜まる
業か行が溜まる それによってどこまで飛ばせるのかと
行為による結果ですね
そうすると認識することっていうのは行為ですからね
行為による結果 だからといって心は自由不自由とはいえません
人間の心は自由ですよとか
いい加減なこと 人間の心は不自由です
それもいい加減なこと
自由不自由の程度の話じゃないんです
でも 私たちから見れば
自分で考えて行動していますね
皆様 今日講演会に来た
皆さんの心が決めたんですね
もしかすると行かないことにする
そうもできたんですね
だから私は自由ではないかと思えるでしょ
これ ほんのわずかなセクションだけです
ほんのわずか自由なところもあります
そういうわけで 仏教は人は自由ですとかは言わない
すべて因縁によりものやと法則ですと言うんですね
はい 次に飛ばしましょう
ワンチャッて終わりました
心っていうのは基本的にどんなものかと
すごいことですよ だって私がっていう場合は心が必要です
私の命というためには心が必要です
心がないと命ではありません
だから物質は全然関係ないんです
はい そこを説明終わってから
六識は何なのかを説明していきます
私たちの世界ね 六識っていうのは我々欲界でしょ
六識の世界 眼耳鼻舌身と心がデータを受け取る場所というね
いうは聞いています 心がデータを受け取る場所
窓口は 5つあります 眼耳鼻舌身といって
データを受け取るための窓口 5つあります
心は外の情報に頼らず
自分自身で認識することもあります
その場合は心に意 あるいはマナと言います
だからヴィンヤーナ 識と言ったっても
あんまり区別はしない方がいいんです
同じことです 私もできるだけ気楽に心心という単語を使っているんです
ここで説明しましょう
目があるから知るね しかし
目目が物質を受け取らないと
知る機能が起きません
知る機能が起きたということは
命ということなんです
あの瞬間で命成り立ったんです
これで耳があるから音を聞くね
だから物質ですよ 音 それで物質を受け取って知る
それで命が現れたんです
あの瞬間で 機能で名前を振ってるだけ
振ってるのは大事じゃないんです
ものがあると思わなくてもいいんです
見る瞬間の命で 聞く瞬間の命は命です
別々です 食べ物を見て
ああ 美味しいなとかね
それを見て 別な生命です
で いろいろ取ったりすると体を動かして認識する
別な生命です それで口に入れちゃうと別な生命です
認識することによって
命 命っていうのは ほんの瞬間
瞬間で成り立って流れていくんです
そこで じゃあ眼耳鼻舌身はものすごくわかりやすいね
この情報なくても 認識するでしょ？難しくない
寝たらどうなる？夢とか見るでしょ
夢は目で見る 目で見ない
ただ勝手に心が回転しているだけ
それで胃が働いているんですね
マナというもの そういうわけで
人間には六根です したがって
眼耳鼻舌身意という認識場所が 6つあって
受け取る情報の種類は色声香味触法と同一です
だから目は何を認識するか分かりきっています
耳は何を聞いているかというと
音を分かりきっています
甘いか苦いか耳にはわかりませんね
それは舌の仕事 舌はうるさいか静かか
舌はわかりません それは耳の話
だからすごい互い違い世界なんです
ですから 色声香味触法束というんです
心は何認識するかというと
何でも だから法という言葉を使うんです
一般的に法というのは物事っていう意味でいいんです
物事といえば何でもでしょう
だからそれはあるものであっても
ないものであっても どうでもいいんです
例えば漫画の世界でね
怪獣とか 手で描いて出すでしょ
手で描いたら目で見えますけど
怪獣はどこに生まれたんですかね
心に生まれたでしょ 存在しないでしょうに
だから心を認識するために物がある必要
必ずあるという必要はないんです
ものがなくても認識する
だから過去のことを妄想するは
将来のことを妄想するは
ひどいことをやっています
そこで六識になるのは
目と色がぶつかると眼識
チャックヴィンヤーナといいますね
耳と声がぶつかると耳識
ソータヴィンヤーナといいますね
鼻と香りがぶつかると耳識
ガーナヴィンヤーナ 鼻識
鼻識ガーナヴィンヤーナ
舌と味がぶつかると 何でしたっけ？読めない
舌識ですね  え？ 舌識です
あ 舌識でしたっけ あ これ専門用語は舌識です
かな これパーリ語で このまあ日本語ではこの色で十分やと思いますけどね
味の色ですから これパーリ語の場合はこのラサ識
ラサヴィンヤーナっていう風に
なんかちょっと語呂が悪かったでしょうね
これで体に何か触れると身識
カーヴィンヤーナが生まれる
胃に物事触れると意識が生まれる
ですから 我々一般的に言っている意識とはちょっと考え違いますね
はい 次 制限についてちょっと考えてみましょう
条件により起こる制限
心は自由自在に無制限に働くことはできません
もうわかったでしょう
制限されています 眼耳鼻舌身という体に囲まれているんです
心をなんか包囲されているんですね
もうカバーをかぶっているんです
かなりきつい頑丈なカバーをかぶっているんです
だから それから漏れるものしか認識できないんです
だから たくさんデータをストップさせちゃうんですね
入る情報は制限されています
いもその情報に基づいて働きます
今はぱっと認識するんだから
理論的には制限がないんです
セオレティカリ これ使って仏教は瞑想を教えてるんです
現実的には我々の思考には制限があります
だから皆様いろいろな思考を妄想しているでしょ？椅子でワンパターンで変えることできないでしょ
もうリミットされているんです
各生命は知る世界が変わるんです
だから 各生命が知る世界がそれぞれ変わっていくんです
それで自分だけの主観
自我の世界を作るんです
これで自我というものが出てくるんです
制限のせいで それで人のことを知ってやることとかね
これはコミュニケーション
ある程度でフィルターをかけたコミュニケーションできるんだけど
できないんです 自分だけの殻ですね
檻の中にいるんです 生命
個っていうのは みんなそれぞれのきつい檻の中にいるものなんです
それであのお釈迦様はすごく言うのは
この知識学問にそんな執着するなよと
見たもの 聞いたもの 考えたもの
感じたものに対して もう放っておけと
そんなのは大したことはない
自分の体の中に受けたちょっとした変化だけなんです
はい その説教はそれで終わって
えーと 何時までやるんですか？今日は
今日は 21時までですね
ということの うん えーと
純粋心って何なのかと
それからパッケージの心
ということは 心とその中身
心を持っちゃうとパッケージで持たなくちゃいけないんです
純粋の心は存在しないんです
認識機能が心純粋だと定義しています
だから認識機能が心だと定義しています
これ定義だけです 出してくれと言ったら出して出してあげることはできないんです
しかし 認識するために条件が必要です
認識することによって心が変わります
だからいつでも何か認識すると条件があって
この条件で知り得るものを知ったんですね
だから条件によって心が変わっているんだから
純粋じゃないんです それは心とその中身という単語を使いますね
用語は心と心情 チッタとチエテシケというんですね
心というのは心 チッタ
チエテシカというのはその中に入っているもの
だから純粋な心はないんです
中に何か入ってるんです
あの条件 ポテンシャル
いろいろ入っちゃうんです
これ私はアビダンマのテキストで例えれば
この 液体とか 我々が飲んだりする液体
我々が飲む液体ってすべて水でしょ？でも純粋水を飲んでいる
誰かが蒸留水 飲まないんですね
おいしくもないし 飲んだら危険でしょうし
だから水に最低酸素ぐらい溶けていないとおいしく感じないんです
だからそのお茶 茶成分を入れたり
コーヒーの成分を入れたり
みかんの成分を入れたり
と アップルの成分を入れたりして飲んでるでしょ？だから純粋な蒸留水は誰も飲みません
そこで 純粋な蒸留水は心と似ていて
これは何か溶けますよ
もういくらなんでも 溶けてから液体というんです
あまり精密な例えじゃないんで
なんとかまあ説明するためにする例えなんですね
だからお茶飲みますと言ったっても
お湯を飲んでるんですよ
お湯と言ったっても 水に熱が入ってるだけで
それだとお湯と言っちゃうしね
お茶飲みますと言っても
まあほんのちょっと成分が入ってるんで
だから成分でお茶というんですね
だから 99.99%水だから水と言っちゃえと言わないんです
あなた何飲んでるの？と言ったら
99 99.9999%の水と茶の成分という言わない
お茶飲んでるんだよと
あんなほんのわずかなところで名前変えちゃいますからね
あれも機能でね 普通のこういうペットボトルの水とお茶
すごい機能が違うんですね
はい 次のテーマに行きます
心の差異 心はいつでも同じものがありません
純粋心は生命に平等であると
理論的立場ですね それは
これはもう科学みたいな話ですから
仏教はね まあ理論上 純粋心だったら認識するだけですから
ミミズであろうが ゴキブリであろうが
私たちであろうが 神であろうが認識しているんですね
同じ機能ですよ 理論的な立場なんですね
心の中に信条で差が起きます
だから 水にほんの 100分の1でも茶成分入れちゃうと
これでもう名前変わってしまいますね
だから ミミズの心と私の心が同じじゃないんです
違うんですよ だからミミズの心に溶けている成分と
私の心に溶けている成分が違うんです
それから善神 悪神 上神
不浄神 理性の人 愚か者などなどは信条の差なんですよ
すごいことを勉強になったんじゃない？あの人怠け者だと言っちゃうでしょ
我々は仏教 仏教も知らない
心理学も知らないのに
あの人は怠け者と言った場合は
その人の心に怠けという成分が溶けているんです
あれは信条の一つなんです
だから心の中にこの怠けという成分が
我々が言っている怠けとは違うんですね
ちょっと違うでしょうね
あの人いつまで怒ってるんだからと言うでしょ
その場合は その人の心に怒りという成分が入っているんです
それで我々は派手にラベルを貼っているんです
あなたは人間ではない獣ですと怒鳴る時も
相手の信条を指しているんです
例えば私が人にあんた人間じゃない獣でしょ？と怒っちゃう
すると私はその人の心の信条
で言ってるんです はい
次 心が変わりますかと
心っていう機能は自由に働きません
信条が必要です 信条が変わると
それに合わせて心 認識機能も変わります
これはこういうこと 例えば
自分の今の心に欲がある
欲があると 自分があえて見るもの
聞くものを選んじゃうんです
欲に合わせて 何でも認識しちゃえばいいのに
そうはしません で 心に怒りがある
怒りがあるで 普段見るものも怒っている
例えば何かあのリビングに落ちている靴だったら
それを取ってどこかに置いておくだけなんですけど
それで怒っている なんでか
ここ こちらにこう置いたのかとかね
誰がこれやったのかで喧嘩を売っちゃうんですね
だから 例えば月曜日はリビングにあの掃除機が置いたまんまで
そこで自分が奥さんも忙しいんだから
自分で掃除機をどこかに置いておく
火曜日はカンカン怒っているんですね
まあそれはわからないんだけどね
そこでリビングにいて
座ってテレビを見ようかなったら
掃除機が邪魔して それで奥さんに怒るんです
なんであんたいつでもこちらに置いたりしてね
片付けないんですか？とか
そういう性格で我々の心が働いているんです
だから心はそうやって信条によって変わることもわかったでしょ
落ち着いていた月曜日は
自分で掃除機をあるべきところに置いて入れてから
ソファに座ってテレビを見た
火曜日はカンカン怒っていたんだから
それをしないで奥さんに喧嘩を売る
えーと 恨みの心と慈しみの心は互い違いますね
だから言いたいのこれなんで
心が同じです 認識しただけ
しかし 認識の中に恨みが入っていた
認識の中に慈しみが入っていた
それによって心が大いに変わります
水に青酸カリ溶けちゃうとどうですかね？毒でしょ
でもこれはもうもう 100 分のあるいはもうもう 0.01%の青酸カリやと思ってもいいんですかね
だから水が変わっちゃったんです
ほんのわずかなことで
そういうことで 我々の心がほんのわずかな信条で派手に変わるんです
それは信条の差です それで私たち人間
お互い違いますね この違いは作るのは信条です
猫と人間が違いますよ
体だけは科学者が勉強していますけど
信条で変わっているんです
本当のところ なんで地球からもらった物質を猫になっちゃったんですかね
そこでその信条が決めちゃったんです
心が猫のお母さんのここ中に現れちゃったんです
そこでもう物質決まってしまいますと
ということで 仏教はね
まあ生命は平等と言いながら
みんな互い違いますよと言っているんです
これ 互い違うと言えると
自分もそうでしょ？朝の自分と昼の自分違うんだから
もうその時その瞬間変わっていくんだから
心身の力が強くなると心も強くなります
だから心というのはいつでも心身次第なんです
心身はどれぐらいある？ 52あります
アビダルのテキストで読んでみてください
数は52ですけど やることはすごいことやっています
はい これでそのセクション終わって別なチャプターに入ります
色蘊という言葉 その時の副題は私とは五蘊のこと
仏教を学ぶ人はいつでも五取蘊という言葉をよく聞いていると思いますね
日本では取っちゃって五蘊と言うんですね
パーリ語でパンチャカンダ
パンチ ウパーダナカンダという言葉ですけどね
うん カンダとは組織 システムという意味です
単一のものではないんですね
物質的な体は色蘊というんです
物質一つだけで我々持っているのは一種類じゃないでしょ
いろいろ物質持ってますね
それは組織になっているでしょ
物質はもうもう酸素 炭素
酸素などなどがもうアミノ酸になっちゃって
それで細胞になっちゃって
細胞は細胞組織になっちゃって
いろいろ組織なんですね
この物質組織はルーパカンダですね
体にいる感覚システム
感じるシステムには受蘊というんです
ウェーダナカンダ 認識するとき現れる参考にする
それから新たに作る無数の概念
想蘊です で 概念結構あるんですね
例えば私 皆様 この舞台の私の方を見たら
こちらこう何か見えるんですね
同じ情報なの こちらに花という概念をつけちゃう
この物体にマイクロフォンという概念を作っちゃう
それに過去の概念も参考にする
新たな概念も作る かなりのシステムですよ
これは想蘊というんですね
サンニャカンダ 心の衝動は行蘊と言います
サンカーラカンダ 心はエネルギーを持ってますよ
そこでこの花です ご飯ですというのは概念で
怒ったら怒りがエネルギーになっちゃうんです
落ち込んだら それ心でエネルギーになっちゃうんです
だから怒りなどなどは行蘊に入るんです
怒りか欲かね 落ち込みか浮きかということで
ここのエネルギーが変わるでしょう
サンカーラカンダ 認識機能は識蘊というんです
その場合 それ純粋に知る機能なんです
はい 五蘊の関係 認識ナーマルーパは相互依存なので
相互依存なので 特定の条件でなければ分離しないんです
私たちの場合はね 体と心っていうのは
どう頑張っても離すことできないんです
一緒に行動するんです
体は心に依存する 心は体に依存する
一つ取り上げようと思っちゃうと壊れてしまいます
それで 名運 ナーマ・カンダ
受想行識運 名運というのは受想行識
つは一体に働きます 分離は不可能です
はい このつは 例えば私は五蘊でしょ
五蘊の中でつは一つで固まる
いくら頑張っても絶対離れることはできません
瞑想して肉体はちょっと離すことはできます
相当瞑想して頑張っちゃうと
これはもう無思惟界の戦場に入ったらね
だからもう普通は無理
それで仏教の二元論でしょ
心と体 心と体といったら
心っていうのは受蘊 想蘊
行蘊 識蘊 つ入っている
システムつ入っているんです
結構膨大ですね 例えば概念のことを考えても
我々はいろんな概念を持ってるでしょ
科学を学ぶは 哲学を学ぶは
政治論を学ぶはね 全部膨大なシステムですよ
あれは 科学のことを喋っている
スイスイ政治のことを私はやっちゃいますけど
行ったりしないでしょ
これそれなりに整理整頓して
で 概念が だからそれだけでもすごいシステムなんです
一般的に心で言っているのは
受蘊 想蘊 行蘊 識蘊というつの組織です
一般社会では 仏教であろうか
他宗教であろうか 心と言った途端
みんなわかってないだけで
あの 受想行識 運にかかっているんです
だから我々も心情のことをわからないんだけど
あの人いつだってニコニコ笑っている
あの人いつだって怒っているという場合は心情
その機能があるから言ってるんです
機能がなかったら単語成り立ちませんだからね
はい 次 心の知る方法 これっておかしい
心は認識機能なので 認識機能で認識機能を認識することはできません
当たり前ですね 包丁は切る道具ですから
包丁でその包丁を切ることはできませんね
この理論を出して 我々仏教をからかっていたんですよ
西洋の人々は あなた方は心を知るということをやって無理だと
などはね 昔ね 今はあまり言わないんで
今は仏教のことを盗み盗みまくってるんです
心は自分と同時に現れる心情を認識するんです
しかし 心には現れると心情はわかるんです
皆さんは朝起きて鏡で自分を見る
あれ自分を見ている？ないんです
いろいろ何が違う あっ
これはぐちゃぐちゃになってるとかね
髪の毛がこうなってるとかね
そういう特色を見ているんです
だから私には心はわからないが
起こっていることだけはわかってますよ
楽しくなったら心はわかりませんけど
今楽しいとわかりますね
すごいシンプルですね
怒り 怒り 嫉妬 舞い上がり
うわつき うちつきなどの心情を知ることは心を知ることです
だから心はいつだって純粋な液体みたいなもんだから
わざわざ知らなくたっていいんです
水は水ではなくて何溶けているのかと
だからスーパーでいろんなソフトドリンクのようにだらーっといろんな種類並んでるでしょ
自分が水で決める？だったら何でも同じことでしょ
だから水で決める必要はないんです
じゃあオレンジジュース買いますと思ったところで
水に溶けているオレンジ成分を考えているんですね
そういうことで 心を知る人は何を知るべきですかね
心情を知るべきなんです
心はあえて知る必要はないんです
拡大した心 狭い心 サマーディ心
サマーディの心などを言う時も
心情と心情で心を発見するんです
経典にはあるでしょ もうサマーディ心が生まれた
混乱の心が生まれた 汚れた心が生まれたとか
四縁処経でね 瞑想すると確認するでしょ
その時心情を確認しているんです
今は心は拡大している
かなり広く活動している
今すごく狭いやとか 今弱いんだと心は
今強いやという場合は
あれは心情で発見するんです
ということは 心が心情によって大きくなったり
小さくなったり 強くなったり
弱くなったりするんです
だから強い心が作りたければ何をするべき？心情を強くするんです
これは良い方で皆さんわからないでしょ？ちょっと機嫌が悪いってことは怒りでしょ
機嫌が悪いことは激怒までできるでしょ
成長することは 人をぶん殴りたくなるところまでこの気持ち悪さが育てますね
その分 心も大きくなっていくんです
ちょっと気持ち悪くなっただけで
我々何もしません 人を殴りません
なので そこは気持ち悪さをどんどん育てる
育てていくと いともたってもいられなくなっちゃって
相手を殴っちゃうんです
ということは 心情が強くなると同時に心も強くなっているんです
そろそろ最後のセクションだとは思います
今日は早く終わりたい
終わりみたい 心の育て方
満たされてない心は物質をいじるが
本質に物質に成長はありません
心を育てるんです 人間やっている愚かなこと
人間が物質に支配されているでしょ
物質の奴隷でしょ 心が気に入らないたびに物質をいじる
物質をいじることで幸せになると思っているんです
金がたくさんなったらとかね
品物をたくさん買ったらとかね
勘違いです 物質には成長ないんです
見たことがある？鉄が成長しましたとか
鉄は鉄です 水素は水素です
炭素は炭素です 成長はありません
炭素の分子構造を変えちゃうとダイヤになりますけど
これは我々にできることじゃないんだからね
だからちょっと調べてみてください
この科学者がね ものすごい研究してるでしょ
物質を成長したことがある？一つもないんです
ただ論理的に成り立たない地球になかった元素をいくつか作っちゃったんだけどね
これ 論理的に考えればあるはずですよと言って研究で作っちゃうと
これ代物で瞬間しか存在しないいくつかの元素がありますよ
作ってもこんな瞬間で消えちゃう
だからといってそれも成長じゃないんです
あるはずものなんです
あるはずですが ない なんとかチャートありますね
あの なんとか何とかピリオディックテーブルで言いますけどね
あのテーブルにある元素はすべて存在しないんです
原子といろいろいろんな分子の計算によって
ここら辺で一個あるでしょうといって名付けちゃうんですね
そこで え ちょっと作ってみようかなと
作ってみたら作られたんだけど
瞬間に消えちゃう だから物質は成長したことは１つもないんです
携帯あるんだから随分発展しているんだよと
何も発展してないんで
ただいろいろ組み合わせただけで
というわけで 仏教は明らかに人間に科学的に正しくというんです
心育てなさいと それに頑張れと
なぜならば育てられます
鉄といくら戦っても 鉄そのものが亜鉛という元素
成長しません それに炭素を入れちゃってね
スチール作るかもしれませんだけどね
ちょっと硬いというね
そんな程度で だから亜鉛っていうのはすごく滑らかいんだからね
すぐ曲がっちゃうし すぐ壊れるし
すぐ燃えちゃいますね
だからいろんなもの入り込んじゃって燃えない鉄が現れちゃいますね
それ いろいろのものを入れることによって
すごい頑丈なスチールとかね
作れますけど 物質の成長ではありません
あれは はい 心を育てるべきです
心を育てるったって もうもう把握できない心をどうするんですかね
純粋心というのは実際しないしね
実際ではなくて 現実的にない
いつでも心情と一緒なんです
竹井で だから私たちは心情を育てるんです
皆様に経験ありますから
怒りを育てたこと 欲を育てた経験あるでしょうに
落ち込みを育てた 引きこもりを育てたとかね
結構修行済んでますね
よかったね 嫉妬を育てるとかね
そういう経験があるんだから
慈しみも育てられます
良い心情を育てられます
喜捨心情 不善心情 善信者という 3種類があります
信者 52 ですけど この 3つに分けています
基礎信条 それから不善信条
善信条 基礎信条はまあ一応放っておきます
あの それほどアクセスできないんです
アクセスできるのは不善信条と善信条
皆様は十分修行を進んでいるのは不善信条ですね
卒業できるところまで
不善信条って 16種類でしたっけね
あ  14 で 不善信条は言わなくたっても育ててはいけません
なぜならば 不善信条を作っちゃうと
心がそれなりに強くなる
強くなって身体と心の関係を悪化するんです
だって身体と心がものすごく離れないでしょ
だからお互いに仲良く活動しないと
肉体は心の機嫌を取ってあげて
心は肉体の機嫌を取ってあげて
この仲良くしないとあまり楽には生きていられません
不善信条を作っちゃうと
この関係悪くなっちゃうんですね
これ 夫婦のたとえで言えば
夫婦は 20年間もうすごい仲良く生活したんだと
喧嘩一つしないで 結婚してもう 1週間経ったところから
もう 20年間も喧嘩ばっかりしちゃったんだと
それで関係でしょ？どちらでも
二人方も離婚する気持ちは全くない
それだったらどんな関係いいんですかね？喧嘩の関係？だから夫婦が喧嘩する関係だったら
夫婦関係っていうのはものすごい気持ち悪くて
もう愚痴が悪くて 家に帰りたくなくなっちゃうし
もう帰った後もコソコソと帰って隠れて自分の部屋に行ったりとかね
すごいなんか関係悪くなっちゃうね
すごく仲良しだったら家に帰りたくてたまらない
帰ったら二人ともニコニコとどうだい
あれやこれや喋ったりとか
何か食べます 食べましょうねとかね
すごくうまくいってるでしょうね
ですから 不善信条は育てるべきではないんです
が それ言う前にもう修行済んじゃったんだからね
だから世の中のみんなの身体と心の関係が最悪状態なんで
それでものすごい悪いことやっています
マインドフルネスなんか持ってきて
もうちょっと体を癒してあげようとかね
それからまた元の悪い関係持っていこうではないかと
そんなことやってはいけないんです
この俗世間の目的で 欲の目的で
商売繁盛の目的でマインドフルネス使ったらもうもったいないんですね
そこであの不善信条を育てると
身体と心の関係が悪化になっちゃって壊れちゃうんだ
早く それから溜まったエネルギーによって悪い次元に生まれるんです
もう仕方がない 変えられない
だから不善信条は作っている間でも
我々は肉体を破壊しているんです
心の力もどんどん弱くなっていくんです
これ 弱くなることは気づかないんですよ
なぜならば 信条が強いと
その分心も強いんです
例えば 怒りが強くなっちゃうと
その分心も強くなります
でも怒りそのものが破壊力を持ってるんだから
体が途端に破壊してくるんです
場合によって他人まで破壊しちゃうんです
それで体早く壊れて低い次元に行ってしまいます
だから不善信条を避けて善信条を繰り返し作ります
方法様々です 善行為をするとかね
体を守るとか 瞑想するとか
講演を始めてやった慈悲の瞑想はとことんやってみるとか
それで善心処を育てます
そうすると体と心の関係が良くなりますし
そうすると寿命を全うすることもできるし
死後もより良いところに高い次元に行っちゃいます
善心処とともに基礎心処は強化します
基礎心処はあんまりアクセスできないんですが
善心処を育てていくと基礎心処も強化しています
それはもう詳しく明確にアビダンマのテキストを開ければ説明できますけど
今日は時間の関係もありますからね
ないと思います 特にヴィパッサナー瞑想では
基礎心処はかなり強くしなきゃダメなんです
はい それで善不善の定義
執着する 依存する方向への認識は不善です
今も私たちの心が物質に依存して執着しているんです
だからそれを応援すると不善なんです
離れることを頑張ると善なんです
アビダンマでは善不善の定義
別になりますよ でもこれはより優れた定義なんです
アビダンマよりも only
離れること に関わる心境は善
例えば戒を守るということをちょっと見比べてください
いろんなことをやめるでしょう
例えば回  5番目 酒は飲まないと
酒飲んでふざけて楽しみたいんですよ
5番目の戒を守る人は
そこから離れるんです
自分のために嘘をつきたいんです
自分の身を守るために
やっぱりいいんです 離れますと
離れるところに善なんです
例えば善行をするとき
ボランティアをするとき
福祉活動をするとき 商売にならないね
あれは まあそれで商売にしている人もいます
けどは 普通 皆様は福祉活動に行ったら
何かもらいたくてやっているわけじゃないんです
商売になってないんです
だから善なんです 離れる
自分のために生きることがちょっと悲しいんですね
自分のために生きることではなく
人を助けてあげることにそのエネルギーを使ったんです
何か儲かったか 何も儲かってないんです
しかし 善心処が 育ちちゃうんです
それで自分が善行をしたんだから
自分がもう高次元の方向へ行くんです
体と心の関係が良くなっちゃうんです
まあ結局はたくさん利得はありますよ
ものすごい利得はあるんだけど
それを狙うんじゃなくて
我々はこの離れることにピンポンするんです
人に 1万円を寄付する
その人はこれを使って何する？ではなくて
自分が 1万円に執着ある
この執着から離れることを気をつけと
そうすると純粋な善になるんです
もらった人は悪いことに使ったからといって
それは自分の罪はないんだからね
関係ないことになるんです
無執着 離れる方向への認識は善です
この ２行を覚えておいてください
これとても良い定義です
離れることの完成は解脱です
仏教で語っている究極の幸福
安穏である涅槃 解脱は離れることの完成なんです
もう何もないんだと もう全部全てから離れましたと
はい あとワンチャプターあります
瞑想実践 心育てることは集中することです
はい 心育てる 信者育てるという話を持ってきたんですね
本当は心育てることはちょっとアクセスできないんで
だから信者育てなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 我々は心育てることを狙っているならば
それはまあ集中瞑想というんですね
サマーディ瞑想ですね
よく言う まあまあ 仏教仲間の中でもね
私が教えているヴィパッサナーはどうったことない
我はアーナパナやってますよとかね
サマーディ瞑想やってすごい威張ってる人々がいるんです
聞いてみるとやり方知らないんですね
教えてくれると 誰々さんのお坊さんで
お坊さんたちはかなりのプロなんですけど
なんかやり方が違うなと思ったりはします
はい  私は論理的に説明していきます
複数の対象を認識すると
心が対象の間で走り回ります
いい加減に認識します
今 皆様方は声は聞こえている
ものは見えている 座っているんだから体も感じているね
足も痛くなっている それからメモも書こうとしている
いろんなことをやっているでしょう
全部いい加減にやっているんです
仕方がないんです 心は全部走り回らなくちゃいかんのだから
例えばお尻が痛くて そちらに気になっちゃうと
私の話の意味がわからなくなっちゃいます
聞いているんだけど いい加減になっちゃうよ
その場合は 誰の心もいつでもそうやって曖昧中途半端でいい加減で認識しているんです
いい加減に認識だから
誰の心も強くないんです
一つの対象を無理に認識させることはサマーディ瞑想です
だから呼吸瞑想はすごい人気があります
呼吸っていうのは肉体が起こしている機能です
それも関わりがあります
物質は呼吸する必要はないでしょう
だから生きているんだから呼吸しているんです
だから でも呼吸そのものが物質的な機能なんです
でも心が割り込んでいるんだから起きているんです
そこでもう花は見ない
音楽も聴かない 呼吸だけに集中してみる
そうすると いい加減な認識ではなくて
より精密に認識できるようになってくるんです
そうすると 心に物事を精密に認識する力がついてくるんです
それはサマーディ世界なんです
しかし そのサマーディを作るのは信条なんです
サマーディという信条があるんです
アビダンマでは一貫性というし
また全心境の中でサマーディという信条を別にも設定しているんです
なんていうのか いい方一貫性というんです
わからない 一境性 一境性というの対象を一つに
ちょっとわざと入れてみる
無執着と離れる方向へ進む対象を選んでサマーディ瞑想を行います
だからサマーディ瞑想の場合も
昔からの瞑想法を決まって教えてあるんです
だからあまり勝手なサマーディやらない方がいいんですね
で 仏教で 40種類のサマーディ瞑想がありまして
そこからとってもヒンドゥー教でも呼吸とかね
やってますから みんな呼吸だけサマーディ瞑想と思って勘違いしてるんですけど
いろいろあります そういうあの
選んで 昔の仙人たちがね
経験者たちが 先輩たちが
これこれいいやというっていうのを選んでほしいんです
あの そこで対象のこの離れることに関わりを持たなくちゃいけない
だから仏教を推薦するのは
呼吸瞑想とこの無常随観
苦随観 不浄随観などで離れる気持ちが必ず生まれます
不浄随観では まあそれほど強烈な禅定が生まれませんだけど
かなり心は成長します
これ なんでこういうことを言ったかというと
このゲームをやっている時も結構集中できますね
面白くない 何でもない
普通のもう知識にもならない
役にも立たない本を読む時はすっと終わりまで読んじゃうでしょ
あれって集中力でしょ
でも役に立たない このテロをやっている人々も
結構時間かけて厳しい修行
呼吸訓練もして 精密にえらい集中力なんです
それは役に立たない 怒り
嫉妬の訓練だから破壊します
地獄に落ちます もう仕方がないんです
だから皆さんも仕事なら集中できるとかあるでしょ
大したことないんです
それは欲の世界ですから
だから心を育てたければ
この離れる対象を何か選んで
無常とかね 苦とかね 生きることは
あるいは体は不浄というね
という何か選ばなくちゃいけないんです
汚れた対象に集中してもサマーディは起きません
ある程度で一挙性は強くなるんだけど
それ以上言っちゃうと体が壊れて死ぬんです
だからサマーディまでいきません
怒りだけ怒りが強くなって発作を起こして死ぬことはあるんです
欲があまりにも強くなって発作を起こし
死ぬことはあるんです
不善の場合 そういうことなんです
だからサマーディまでいけません
ある程度強くなりますけど
あまりにもやばいんですね
ですから 善の方でサマーディを作らなくちゃいけないんです
そこでヴィパッサナー瞑想って何なのかと
難しいですけど ヴィパッサナー瞑想はちょっと難しいんです
認識機能を育てるんです
要するに認識機能って心なんです
微妙なところで この心そのものを育てなくちゃあかんです
ヴィパッサナーでは そうすると論理じゃない
ないことなんです だからブッダしかそれを発見しなかったんです
このマインドフルネスというものは誰も発見してないんです
だって論理上 心にアクセス不可能です
みんな信条と戦っているんです
信条しかどうにもならない
これはヴィパッサナーの精密理論なんですね
プリンシプルです 認識機能
認識する機能に心という
その認識する能力をしっかり育ててみるんです
わかるでしょ？なんで認識に制限入ります？信条
肉体 だからものすごく壁が壁が壁があって
漏れるものしか認識できるんです
結果としてありのままに物事を認識できて
真理を発見するんです
だから信条はそれほど関係ないんです
心には認識機能が強くなっちゃった
壁は関係ない ありのまま認識しちゃう
すぐ直ちに出脱に達します
成功すると輪廻転生を終える終えるんです
あの苦しみの循環がすべて終わっちゃうんです
それも信条に頼れないと実践は不可能んです
理論は理論ですけど そこで私はこの間
いいヴィパッサナー瞑想ありますから
やってくださいと言われたら
すごい異様な顔しちゃったんですね
まあやらないでしょうと思います
その方 私は言ったのはね
スローモーションで実況しながらティッシュ 1枚を取って折ってみてくださいと
それも精密に完璧に折ってくださいと
これって正真正銘のヴィパッサナー瞑想なんですよ
実況中継するのは この余計な信条が思考が入らないためなんです
だからティッシュを取ります
取ります 取ります これもう取ること
認識機能できているでしょ
それでもう置きます 置きます
置きますと それから精密だから
角 角 角とかね 綺麗に合わせてやらなくちゃいけないんです
2つに折ったらまた 4つに折る
それ終わったら八つ八枚に折る
折るたびに折り方が変わっていく
それ以上は完璧には折れませんね
人間の手では それでみんなこれって瞑想かいと
アメリカ人に聞くそうって気持ちでしょうね
アメリカ人がそこまで知っているかどうかと
あれって相当難しいんですよ
私もやってみて なかなかもう 80点にはならないね
点数で言えば あれほど気をつけてやっているのに
だからそこで智慧が現れてくるんですね
ティッシュ 1枚 1枚 別々な存在で
機械で切って運んでいるんだから
みんな同じやと思っているだけで
ティッシュ 1枚1枚は同じじゃないんです
頭で四角で長方形でしっかりとカットして機械切るんだからね
思っているでしょ？そうじゃない
まっすぐじゃないんです
それから紙っていうのは繊維ですから
この繊維の形によって折っても
ちょっとこう ちょっとあっち向くんですよ
あれは 0.01 ミリかもしれませんだけどね
だからわかるでしょ？一個一個違う世界でいるということ
一期一会の世界にいること
1枚は折って ほぼ 80%成功したら集中力を持ったんだから落ち着いてます
すごい安らぎを感じるんです
その時は だってこれ離れる世界の修行だからね
そうするとちょっと調子に乗りやがっちゃって 2
枚目折ることすると 60点になっちゃうんですね
そう簡単な修行じゃないんです
でも本格的な修行です
はい だからこの認識機能を育てる瞑想であっても
信条に頼るんです ではどんな信条に頼るのかというと
気づき サティという信条に頼るんです
よりすごい大騒ぎしている信条なんです
気づき サティ だから気づくために
やっぱり私は実況中継しなさいと言っているんです
ラベル貼ってくださいということも使ってますけどね
ラベルはもうどうったことないんだけど
実況するとこの瞬間に気づいているんですね
それで気づく機能がしっかりするんです
気づく機能が成長すると
それで認識機能も成長しているんです
なぜならば この気づきと認識っていうのはものすごい相性がいいんです
ほとんどペアなんです
だからお釈迦様がまず気づきということで
これ唯一な道であると説くんです
ものすごい心の精密科学者なんですよ
これは現代科学者にはまるっきり理解できない世界で
あの真理の中で気づきという真理を発見して
これ育てましょうよと
それで悟りを開くために
気づきから始めて 徐々に善心所を育てるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想というと
まず気づき心所を育てていくんです
気づき心所が大きくなってくると
他の善心所もついてくるんです
それでかなりパワフルな心所が生まれてくるんです
それで 初めからの気づきは王様だから
認識機能が強くなっていくんです
そこはサマーディ瞑想と違うところなんです
あまりサマーディ瞑想を作ろうとしないんです
必要な善心所は教えてありますよ
仏教で あの七覚支三十七菩提分布とか言ってみたら見つかります
五力 五根 いろいろ用語で
説かれています で ちょっと瞑想もういかないんだったら
そこに参考してみるんです
気づきがうまくいかないと
何かなにかついでに必要な心所が弱いということなんです
四念処とは気づきの育て方です
この四念処経がありまして
これは一貫して気づきの育て方なんです
いろんなものを気づく方法を教えてあるんです
ヴィパッサナー実践の修行者はあえて無執着
離れることに重点を置きます
それでサマーディ瞑想はサマーディ作りたいんです
光みたい 一体感感じたい
我という気持ちをいろいろ欲の目的があるんです
ヴィパッサナー実践者には無執着
離れることをさせてくださいと言うんです
私の言葉で 私は皆様に瞑想しろというのは
放っておきなさいと これ育てなさいと
同じ離れる言葉なんです
何があっても放っておきなさいと
放っておけない気になるって執着ですね
これから進めなくなっちゃうんです
それで ヴィパッサナー実践者は何に重点を置きますかというと
離れることに 無執着に
放っておくことに執着
ヴィパッサナー瞑想うまくいこうがないかではなくて
放っておけるのかということに気をつけてください
集中力は欠かせないが
目標ではありません 集中力はもうパッケージで入ってきます
気にする必要はないんです
パッケージに入っているんだから
わざわざそれにお金を払って買う必要はないんです
携帯買ったら充電するあれもついてくるでしょ
わざわざそれ買わなくてもね
次 ちょっと難しいところにあります
解脱を認識すること 認識するとは
認識対象を認識することです
識が対象を認識することです
一切の対象は無常です
結局は それでハテナ入れちゃったんです
まあちょっと面白くて
認識が起きないという認識は？なんか変でしょ
解脱を認識すること 心です
認識が起きないという認識が起こるんです
もうもうもう頭がこんがらがっちゃいます
あれ？何と だからこれには語ってはいけないし
説法してもいけないし
認識が起きない心を認識する
それは解脱を体験したってことなんです
お釈迦様はヴィンヤーナンアニダッサなんていう言葉で
特色を持たない認識 我々はすべて特色で認識するんです
例えば これはテーブルです
これは花ですね どうやって認識した？テーブルはテーブルの特色を持っている
花は花の特色を持っている
このサッ ディファレンス
区別 これで認識が起きるんです
区別はないと認識すると
例えば皆様の空気を認識できる
いっぱいでしょ ホールの
なんて区別がないんです
ちょこっと線香で煙出ちゃったら見えるでしょ
あれも空気でしょ なんで見える？特色あるからなんです
たとえ書いた 無数の形の風船を飛ばしましょう
風船を見れば空気の形見られるね
ハートの形 犬の形 もうかぼちゃの形
いろんな形 無数の形の風船をもう空気入れて飛ばしちゃう
飛ばしちゃうと風船見えちゃうと何が見えますかね？あの空気の形見えるんです
風船という特色をとって
風船を割ってみて 空気を認識しましょう
無数の形の風船とはどういうこと？ 風船はいろいろ形あるでしょ
大体丸い  え？まあ例えだからあると考えましょう
もう 1億ぐらい風船の形あるんだけど
で 現実的にあるわけじゃないんだからね
例えばいろいろ形の風船はね
まあ一応また現実的にいろんな形で風船を作っちゃっても
どんどん膨らませちゃうとどんどん丸くなっていくんです
それはそれは物質の働きでそうなるんですけどね
そんな話しちゃうと もうたとえで使えなくなっちゃいますからね
で 風船見ると空気の形見えますね
風船割ってみたら空気がなくなったわけじゃないでしょ
だからまあそこはそんなもんですね
涅槃の認識っていうのは
解脱の認識っていうのは
これは体験する人にしかもう語れないものになっちゃうんです
特色がないこと それで話が無事終わりました
どうしますか？えーと
ね あの   ちょっと何か言われると困りますから
あの なんで仏教はこの認識
色に対してそれほど詳しいかというと
世間ではこの色とは私である
私の魂であると言って執着するんですね
なぜならば 色はものすごい速く
恐ろしい速さで変わるんですね
そうすると あるのように錯覚が起こるんですよ
あの扇子を回しちゃうと
火の輪っか見えるでしょ？ゆっくり回すと扇光見えるんですね
だから光の速度よりもものすごい速さで心が回転するんだから
私がいる 私がいるという幻覚が起こるんです
だから仏教はこの自我がありません
霊魂がありません すべて無我だよと
だから執着捨てること
それで解脱解放やと言っている世界なんです
だから全く宗教と関係ない世界なんです
だから色についてかなり詳しく語るんです
前も言ったでしょ 何か見た瞬間で別な自分
聞くやった瞬間で別な自分なんです
全く同一同じ自分じゃないんです
もう中身まで変わっちゃったんです
その流れ 誤解するんですね
錯覚起こるんですね これはヴィパッサナー瞑想で発見しなきゃいけない
このチャンナというお坊様がいて
自殺したくなっちゃったんですね
私 注釈書を読んでないんだから
この理由はわからない
で 自殺したくて この剃刀
昔の怖い剃刀 プロが使っている
剃刀を持ってよく準備して
じゃあ首を切ると それでサーリプッタ尊者とマハーチュンダという大尊者二人が
この話を聞いてさっさと行って
やめてくださいと頼むんです
最初の尊者の頼み方はすごいんです
あなたの面倒を見る人をね
お世話する人がなかったら
私自身がお世話して面倒を見てあげるんだと
あなたに食べ物とかお布施とかね
入らないんだったら 私自身で持ってきてあげますよと
だから自殺をやめてちょうだいと言ったら
マハーチュンダ長老は
いえ 私は別に必要なものは揃っている
お世話する人もいるし
お布施ももらっている
結構ですと すべて揃っている
心配しなくても結構ですと
しかし自殺しますよと
それでもう仕方がない
それでこうやって失踪するんです
チャックハウスチャックヴィンヤーナンチャックヴィンヤーナヴィンヤーネヴィンヤータッベダンメ
エタマメエトーハマスエスーメアッタディサマヌパッシシ
サッササティヒワトシマ
目 それから眼識 それから目に見えるもの
色識ですね それに対してあなたはこれが私です
これが私の魂ですと思っている
それから耳 耳に入る耳の耳識
耳識 それから音 そこであんた
私 私の魂と思う それで六根まで聞くんです
ただ 答えは チャックンアウスサーリプッタチャックインニャーナンチャックインニャータッビーダンメーネータママネーソーハマッセネーメーソーアッタ
ってサマナサーリプッタソンジャ
私は目は私ではありません
私の魂でもありません
眼識も私ではありません
私のものでもありません
見えるものは私ではありません
私の魂でもありません
と眼耳鼻舌身まで そう思っています
私は全然 すごいでしょう
次に聞くんです では聞きます
なんで目に対して 眼識に対して
見えるものに対して 私ではありません
私の魂ではありません
私のもではありませんと
あんたなんでそう思っている？と六識について質問していくんです
これ六識も聞かなくちゃいけないんです
で 答えるんです 経典は省略ですけどね
チャックスミンアウスサーリプッタチャックヴィンヤーニチャックインヤータッビーダンメスニローダンディスワニローダナビニャーヤ
私はね 目見ても眼識を観察しても
目に見えるものを観察してても
全部消えているんだと
瞬間だと発見しています
この瞬間で わかっているんだと
ニローダン・ディスワ
滅することを見たんだと
経験しているんだと だから私ではありません
私の魂でもありません
私のものではありませんとわかってますよ
そんなのは 全部消えるものだと
で 六処まで同じフレーズでいきます
それでどうなったかというと
えーと どうなったっけ？それでもう一つ
すごい難しいフレーズで
チュンダ長老がものすごい難しいって
深く的なひとフレーズを言ったんですね
あのー暗記していたつもりですけど
忘れちゃった チャリタス
ちょっと難しいフレーズでも依存すると動揺がある
依存しないと動揺がない
動揺がなければ 依存もしないし
そうするとあんた こちらでもないし
あちらでもないし 間でもないんだよと
これ覚えておきなさいと
マハチョン長老 その一行だけで
で 二人で帰ったんですよ
帰ってすぐもう首を吊っちゃったんです
そこでこの執着ある死に方は惨めであるというテーマでサーリプッタおっしゃってたから
サーリプッタあれほど頑張ったのに
私が教えますと言ったのにね
それで首を吊っちゃった後
報告が入ったら サーリプッタがあまりうまくいかなかったっていう感じなんですね
そしたらお釈迦様がね
あのね お釈迦様が言ったんです
自分が自分なりに頑張りましたけどね
あのね あんた教えたでしょ
死にちょっと前に あの
無執着しない生き方 素晴らしくて
無執着の死に方は惨めと教えたでしょうにと
だからチュンダはね 無執着の心で亡くなったんだから気にすんなよと
だから大阿羅漢なんです
だから首を自殺する前にもう阿羅漢になっていたんです
だからなんで自殺したのかというのは
我々には理解できない
おそらくもう何か体が持つ意味がなくなっちゃったでしょうね
病気か年かなんかね 何としてでも 1 日でも生きてやるぞっていうことはなくて
なんで 1 日延ばすのかと
すべて無常だから だからまあ首を吊っちゃいましょうということだとは思います
はい これで話は終わりです
ありがとうございました
ちょうど9時になりましたので
今日の講演会終了すると思いますけど
はい 閉会文と唱えて終了します
一緒に唱えましょう ドゥッカッパッタ チェニン ドゥッカ
バヤッパッタ チェニン バヤ
ソッカッパッタ チェニン ソッカ
ホントゥ サッテーピ パーニノ
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]